dans les rues de marseille la colère des
infirmiers anesthésistes diplômés d'état
ne faiblit pas depuis plus d'un an il
dénonce l'absence de volonté
gouvernementale d'accéder à leurs
revendications qu'il juge pourtant
légitime rallier sous la bannière ya de
united ils ont lancé un appel à la grève
ce lundi via un mouvement social baptisé
semaine noire on est une profession en
colère depuis des mois et des mois pour
un problème de reconnaissance de notre
statut il ya des décrets qui sont sortis
et des nouvelles
professions qui ont été créés par le
gouvernement donc les affaire de
pratiques avancées depuis 60 ans ou voir
même plus que nous existons nous sommes
dans la pratique avancée et danse dans
cette nouvelle loi nous n'existons pas
et nous sommes mis complètement à
l'écart à l'hôpital de la timone une
soixantaine de grévistes ont été
recensés soit 100 % de l'effectif le
mouvement a causé le ralentissement du
fonctionnement des blocs opératoires de
moitié et les hyades préfère rester dans
la rue il estime n'avoir rien à perdre
nous craignons qu'à terme il y une
pénurie d'infirmiers anesthésistes que
les infirmiers ne vais plus faire cette
profession parce que pour 13 euros de
plus par mois le jeu n'en vaudrait pas
la chandelle au vu des risques que nous
prenons tous les jours et de la
dangerosité potentielle de ce que nous
faisons tous les jours autre point de
discorde les propos d'olivier ferrand
qui a qualifié les infirmiers
anesthésistes de techniciens je pense le
vérin pas dû souvent mettre les pieds au
sein des blocs opératoires et n'a jamais
dû travailler avec des infirmiers
anesthésistes c'est une véritable
insulte une prof de déni c'est la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase après
un an de négociations auprès du
gouvernement pour obtenir ce qui nous
revient de droit réunis symboliquement
devant l'ordre national des infirmiers
les grévistes dénoncent également la
politique menée par le conseil de
l'ordre il s'avérait que
aof lors de négociations il semblerait
que certains membres de l'ordre
nationale et discréditer nos
revendications le gouvernement prend le
risque que le sur la prochaine pandémie
la prochaine vague ou dans l'avenir eden
on ne puisse pas répondre aussi
efficacement à la crise d'autres
mouvements similaires ont eu lieu ce
lundi en france où exerce près de 11000
infirmiers anesthésistes diplômés d'état
face à l'ampleur de la mobilisation
la grève a été prolongée jusqu'au 18
novembre prochain